Hey,
what's going on?
It's bill burn his time for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
Jess,
get in on you,
checking in to see how your week's gone.
Four,
it gets started.
This is going to be a special podcast.
So I have a couple of special amount announcements.
Uh,
Steven Adler is back together with Adler's appetite and they're going to be
playing at the,
uh,
the Rose in Pasadena on August 23rd.
And then he's going to be in Vegas at the Golden Nugget on the 24th.
And on the 25th.
This is August,
August dates at the Canyon club in Santa Clarita.
If you want to see one of the best drummers I've ever seen in my life,
checkout Adler's appetite,
um,
we'll have a link and all that type of stuff.
Go on and go check out Jesus.
I forgot to promote a couple of things.
All right.
Uh,
number one,
I'm going to be at Madison Square Garden.
November 7th for the New York comedy festival.
Tickets are on sale now.
I believe that's a Wednesday Hump Day.
Everybody.
Um,
and uh,
I didn't read the one read.
I had Hubble.
Everybody.
Do you have eyes?
Did they not work as well as they should?
Do you like spending less money on things more than more money on things?
Do you know what the Internet is?
If you answered yes to any or all these questions,
then visit Hubble contacts.com uh,
motivate your audience.
Choose one or two.
All right.
I guess these are positive things.
Talk about how you've been wearing huddled contacts for the past 25 years.
I have it before I didn't see things and now I see I didn't wear those fucking
things.
I don't have contacts.
I have no idea.
I don't know what they're saying.
These guys make contact lenses and they're,
they're fucking great.
How was that?
With humble,
you'll get a fresh pair of lenses for every single day for less than 60,
for less.
60 contacts for 33 bucks.
Do the math.
That's barely a dollar a day.
This is way more affordable than other brands.
Go to Hubble contacts.com and get your first two weeks for free.
Hubble sells directly to you so they can offer a context at a more affordable
price.
They can send you to an optometrist if you don't have a prescription featured in
vogue,
Gq,
tech crunch,
Mashable,
and now the Monday morning podcast or Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Um,
so do what I evidently did 100% and go to Hubble contacts.com and get your first
two weeks of lenses for free.
Uh,
that's Hubb Ellie contacts.com.
And with that,
the other announcements I have to make,
I have a very special guest,
a long time waiting,
long time in the coming for whatever web.
A fucking reason.
We've hung out a million times.
We never thought to do a podcast.
I didn't want to infringe on the man's talents.
Um,
please welcome Mr. Rhodes.
Yay.
Yay for me.
What's up brother?
How are you brother?
I'm doing good man.
I'm so sad.
You're on the podcast.
You're one of the,
one of the best comic side know I've known you for like,
I know I've known you for like 20,
I don't know how many years.
All the way back in La.
And I would say I was living in New York like 98 99 was that it?
I think,
yeah,
maybe that was what it was.
I thought I met you in like 95 or 96 out here in la who's out here
briefly.
You probably walked by with,
you're a romantic novel hair that you had back the romance novel haircut.
I meet with my red Afro Two hacks passing in the night.
Right.
Trying to get better.
And then,
yeah.
And then I think at first time I like officially kind of met you and was hanging
out back when we both had folic strength.
Yes.
And I was very excited that you knew who I was because I had seen you at eating
it of all places,
which is why I became a huge fan of your stand up.
I've told you this story before.
We're going to tell the listeners where you were,
uh,
you were talking about some sort of extra curricular activity that you were
doing.
I had done mushrooms in Amsterdam in Vondelpark.
Yes.
And I just remember you were describing the whole fucking trip of it and I just
remember you were just at one point you were just like,
I was running through the grass summit tippy toes and I was just something about
that was like,
you know,
there's,
with alcohol there's nothing worse than just seeing somebody who's like
completely fucked up.
But like with mushrooms,
there's like a oneness with the world where you literally watching adult become
a child or something.
I just thought you'd described it.
I've never taken mushrooms,
but like from what I've seen when I've seen people tripping and I was there
with,
with Nia way back in the day when we were still boyfriend girlfriend and we
would die in laughing and that became like,
you know,
like one of the,
a catch phrase for us,
we would just be walking around the apartment and one would be in the other room
and we just,
we just yelled at out,
we're not do the grass on my tippy toes.
We both would just start laughing.
That's the greatest compliment you could get when like,
uh,
a joke or a sentence from a joke becomes part of somebody's vernacular,
you know?
Oh yeah.
There's been a few,
there's the Dave Chappelle,
Dave Chappelle had a bit about,
uh,
how,
you know,
he likes it and checking it and he's a black dude.
So there's that weird sort of stereotype,
but he's like,
but,
but I like it.
He goes,
but I won't eat it in public because he goes,
I'm afraid there'll be some white people around going,
look at him.
He loves it.
So just like the encyclopedia says,
it wasn't that the last line of that bit.
I don't remember,
but I just submit it to this day.
I know I can't eat without thinking to that line.
Well,
to this day when me and Nia are hanging out,
uh Oh,
if we're eating food and if she go as a taste,
I go,
oh,
that's good.
I like it.
And she'd just go look at him.
He loves it.
But like,
it just,
it's just,
there was a few of those.
Yeah.
Now I got to go through all of them.
Sarah Silverman.
Sarah Silverman said something about how she always Prac bought condoms or
something.
I forget.
I just remember that was the punchline was cause I do a lot of fucking,
Neil was watching that.
We're in this little one bedroom apartment in is everything is in New York
little and I was shaving in the other room and I just heard that I didn't even
believe we're here.
The setup,
which probably why I can't remember it by just bursted out laughing while I was
shaving.
So,
um,
anyway,
you pardon my mount Rushmore of lines that just never,
it never,
it just never left my,
my,
my head.
I don't know why.
So.
And furthermore other,
you know,
I would say either you or Doug,
Stan hope
have probably put the most like
stand up miles on the odometer as far as the places that,
that you've played,
how far you've gone.
Um,
but I mean you might have to be the king man.
You were telling me that at some point in this podcast you are going to start
rattling off your dates.
If it actually,
you sat down here looking like you didn't have a care in the world and you just
casually mentioned to me that you're off to Mongolia tomorrow.
Yeah,
yeah.
I would be a fucking wreck going like,
Oh I,
what am I going to forget?
Something I would have to check 50 times to make sure I have my passport and I
would stick it in the bag and I would zip it shut and then look to make sure and
I would zip and shut again and then I would still have to check it before I left
the house in the car on the way to the airport before I started talking that
anxiety down because
is my,
um,
Genghis Khan biography to reread on the plane.
That's it.
Does that how you say it?
It's not gang.
Yeah.
W I played in Mongolia last October and it was freezing.
It was in the third.
So this is the,
you're the only guy I know.
Natalie's Ben to Mongolia Open.
Notice the way return engagement,
it's triumphant return to Mongolia.
You awesome.
The comedians,
they're wonderful guys.
I mean in Mongolians are beautiful and they look like the people in the Avatar,
but without the blue.
And uh,
five of the low five of the local Mongolian comedians met me at the airport when
I arrived and they,
they cheered when I came out.
I'm like the most famous comedian that's ever played in Mongolia,
so they'd like bend over backwards showing me,
uh,
Ulaan Baatar and we drove out to the,
the world's largest Genghis Khan's statue.
And Yeah,
they taught me that it's a,
it's Genghis Khan,
not Angus.
And those,
well,
I like a,
you're not obnoxious with that information.
You could be really conti at a party.
Excuse me guys.
I don't interrupt.
Genghis Khan.
Yeah.
And Americans and other people say though,
they call those white round tents a Yurts,
but they actually call them GIRs in Mongolia.
So what's,
what's the,
uh,
I don't know anything about it other than it's just sort of spoons with northern
China.
It's between them and Russia and China and Russia and a,
so I liked it so much and um,
I wanted to go back in summer and see it when it wasn't,
um,
bone chilling cold.
So it's kind of um,
uh,
vacation.
So I mean I'm going to do a gig there,
but I'm going to go in and I'm,
I'm,
I'm going to spend like four days there.
These guys are going to take me way out into the country.
We're going to sleep and occur.
One of those round tents.
Um,
shoot,
shoot some arrows,
do some,
uh,
do some Mongolian warrior activities.
And then I got a Gig.
You got to tell Rogan about this.
Rogan sounds like he would be all over the sure.
He would love it.
I'm sure you would love it.
It's um,
you know,
that's the,
I've shot some arrows in my time.
I went,
I went both fishing and some by you down and fucking hour with it was somewhere
outside of New Orleans.
It's a great thing about being a comedian.
I remember I was in Alaska years ago.
I did a Gig and catch a can and I met the perfect Alaskan Guy who took me
fishing on his charter boat and then took me skeet shooting.
I just feel like when you meet those guys,
there's always some sort of like raggedy plane.
Do you get in first that lands on water or they put snowshoes on bottom of it in
place
upon tune.
So what,
let's see.
You know,
you're the only guy in all that's played Vietnam.
I love Vietnam.
You know my,
yeah.
Like I know that watches like Ken Burns documentaries like,
yeah,
I've been there.
I've played there.
Yeah,
I know what it looks like.
No,
I've done all of that.
Um,
I,
you know,
well,
I did that special for comedy central in 1995 called Viva Vietnam.
I W I got to go to Vietnam.
You've been going there.
I was like eight years.
I was the first comedian ever to have a development deal with comedy central and
so I could do whatever I wanted.
It was like being a junior filmmaker almost.
So.
Oh.
And they was [inaudible] 94 Bill Clinton lifted the travel ban on Vietnam.
The way like Obama lifted the travel ban on Cuba and my father fought in
Vietnam.
He flew helicopters.
He was shot down everyone in his helicopter.
Can you tell that story?
Uh,
yeah.
Quickly.
Yeah.
So,
and this is why Vietnam has always been a really important,
it's a been a big thing in our family.
Um,
so my father flew helicopters in Vietnam in 1969.
He was stationed in [inaudible] and uh,
he,
there was,
there was all these soldiers stuck on the ground.
They're surrounded by,
uh,
the north Vietnamese soldiers in there.
They're just getting slaughtered.
So my father had to fly in and rescue these guys.
How old was he?
Um,
he actually joined my,
my dad was one of those knuckle heads,
so he was 30.
His,
uh,
his buddies in his unit called him [inaudible] because he was like the oldest
guy there because everybody else was 19.
You know,
he just thought,
you know,
he grew up on John Wayne movies.
He thought that,
you know,
he was one of those guys that thought in your country needed you,
so,
uh,
they made,
he made,
I got the letter from the army,
uh,
in all his metals,
um,
after he died.
Uh,
so he made three attempts to land to save these guys and was,
it took so much heavy fire,
he had to lift up,
circle around and on the fourth attempt he gets down and there's like 20 guys
down there,
it's still alive and it's life or death.
So they all like jump on the,
the helicopter as he's pulling up,
you know,
and these just getting rattled with so much,
um,
fire machine gun fire that the helicopter nose dived down and everybody died in
the helicopter except for him and his copilot who was knocked unconscious,
he unhooks him,
dragged him across the field under heavy fire and then they had to wait there
for like an hour or two before someone could come in and rescue was shooting
back at them or what?
Well,
it's funny,
he,
cause he,
you know,
he,
my dad,
uh,
would laugh when he tells his story because he always had this pistol that he
would take with him when he,
when he was flying.
And then the one day he forgot it,
he gets shot down.
So he wasn't shooting back,
he didn't have a gun.
So,
um,
my dad was a decorated war hero and he,
he got like five metals via house.
He,
uh,
Tom has it framed,
he has the letter and,
and there's like,
you know,
the little from the army is saying what he did from his commanding officer and
there's almost not enough room in the frame for all of the medals.
Like five,
there's like six medals,
but five were from that one incident.
He got the distinguished flying cross and,
and,
uh,
my,
my father,
um,
is buried in Arlington national cemetery as he should.
And you've got to be a bad ass to get in there.
You know,
I would say he qualifies.
So my dad,
uh,
probably be buried across the street and like sort of a seven 11,
I want to viking funeral pyre.
Um,
so,
so my dad,
every year he would get,
he would have a reunion with his Vietnam veteran helicopter buddies.
And it was like,
um,
big thing for him.
Uh,
and,
uh,
and you know,
my dad also loved stand up comedy.
My Dad loved prior and my dad's the reason I'm a comedian,
you know,
he had all,
I remember driving around with it as a little kid listening to Richard Pryor
with my dad.
So as he thrilled that you became a comedian?
Oh yeah.
My Dad drove me to my first open mic night.
My Dad,
my dad.
So my dad stayed up.
Comedy was always revered in my family and well especially,
you know,
because my dad and he just,
uh,
my dad wore shipped prior.
He had a Bob Newhart records and tasted great tastes too.
Yeah.
So I,
I,
um,
I think those were like my two biggest influences as a kid.
And then my family is from Washington DC and my uncle did open mic nights for
one year in 1978.
I'm 11 years old.
My Dad took me to see my uncle performance is open Mike night.
And it was a club called El Brooklyn's in DC.
And the entrance was next to the stage,
the shows in progress.
We walk in,
I'm wearing a Washington Redskins jacket.
The comedian onstage pulls me on stage and he starts interviewing me like I'm
the coach of the Redskins and I'm like,
I'm 11.
I'm a bashful,
dopey kid.
I give you one word answers.
Yes,
no,
but I'll never forget standing on that stage and seeing all those happy people
with their heads thrown back and laughter and all the teeth in their mouth.
And that moment changed my life.
And I,
you know,
and I,
I just,
I can,
I can still picture it.
You know,
it's,
I,
you know,
um,
black people,
Latin people,
white people,
like Asian people,
just the flavors of humanity.
And I just thought that that was the most magical place in the world to stand on
stage,
making people laugh.
So,
um,
I became a student of comedy after that and would keep notebooks and then I
started when I was 17 with a fake id.
You still have all your,
yeah.
Comedy.
You like your apartment,
first of all,
it's cool as shit.
It's also like this,
uh,
it's the Smithsonian of your life and he has his dad's helmet from Vietnam when
he was shot,
the one that he was wearing.
Um,
I got chills looking at that thing.
Yeah.
Like that's like a imagine brain when he was wearing that and you were told me
the story as we were sitting there smoking a wonderful cigar.
Uh,
and you told me this story and then to s and you're like,
I still have the Helen.
And I was like,
Oh wow,
man.
I couldn't believe it.
Then to walk in and see it and after it and just the heaviness of it once it's
like a story attached to it.
Like if you just got a helmet and it was like,
yeah,
this is like,
uh,
you know,
some memorabilia thing.
This is,
and you have to wonder what happened to actually know what happened while the
thing was,
I mean,
I'm into that type of shit.
Like,
I got that weird thing of like,
um,
if I know the story behind it,
which is why I have to be careful because I'll,
I'll just fill my house up with a bunch of shit like that.
And then I have all this fucking anxiety that I have no place to send anything
down.
You know,
I kinda have this thing cause I kind of grew up with semi hoarders that just
would not fucking throw anything out,
you know,
40 years of magazines and Shit.
Um,
no,
that's the cool thing about,
you know,
I had everything in storage for 10 years.
I just traveled the world.
I decided not to live anywhere.
Do you think his,
his,
so I got to preserve all these great things,
you know,
what do you think your dad being in Vietnam and then you learning about that,
is that how you got the travel bug to the level you do your unlike some Tom
Brokaw level shit
maybe.
And My mother's from Argentina,
so I don't know.
I mean I had performed everywhere in the United States,
you know,
20,
30 times and I wanted to branch out.
Um,
but,
but back to Vietnam,
I mean that was a really special thing for me to go there.
And I filmed this hour special called Viva Vietnam for comedy central.
It was like a travel log type
of thing.
Um,
did the Jane Fonda workout tape in Hanoi with some old women in a park when
Denay China beach set up a slippery slide.
People about why Jane Fonda is funny for them.
I Vietnam veterans hate Jane found his guts still to this day.
Veterans,
um,
at those Vietnam reunions,
my dad would go to,
they still sell the Jane Fonda,
um,
urine,
uh,
the thing for like a urine old guard with her picture on it.
You know what I'm,
you ever seen a urinal cake?
Yeah.
It will know like the little plastic thing on it.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
Um,
Vietnam War Jane Fonda goes to Hanoi,
the um,
uh,
the capital of the people were having a war with and she's antiwar and,
and,
and they took pictures of her own,
like anti aircraft artillery and,
and then she met the POW yes.
And one of them slipped her a note.
And then she,
uh,
apparently,
if I remember the story correctly,
she gave that to the Vietnamese prison guards and Oh,
the guy was tortured to extra for,
I'm slipping her a note.
Oh God,
that's fine.
That's has to be the ultimate,
uh,
stupid celebrity moment.
Yeah.
Where you're,
you're just so like,
you know,
sucking the Dick of your own fucking ego that you,
you go and do something like that to just,
why are they being against a war zone?
That's fine.
Thick.
You'll go to the capitol and watched enough war movies that my heart would be in
my fucking throat.
The second you get the note,
you're like,
do I got to put this under my tongue of put it up my ass?
Like what do I gotta do?
I gotta do it.
I know this is like some top secret shit,
Huh?
Yeah.
Um,
but so in,
in 1990 we filmed was guard.
He met you.
He
asked,
Matt slipped me a note.
Um,
he'll need extra bamboo under his fingernails.
Uh,
so 19 September 94,
we filmed it.
And like Americans,
it was only like,
that's,
that went there.
Like,
it hadn't become like a tourist place yet.
So,
and this park and in Hanoi,
a old women would gather and do Tai Chi in the morning.
So at the time,
[inaudible] 94,
beginning,
early nineties,
Jane Fonda was making these exercise tapes and we set up a television with a VCR
and we brought the tape in 1994 technology,
we had to run an extension cord like five blocks to,
to set this up in the park.
And these old women loved it.
They took to it and they started doing it.
And she goes,
I turned it as she goes,
now turned to the right and I'll say,
I,
I'll say she turned to the right.
Did she?
Oh,
did you see,
uh,
can you imagine her fucking agent when she was telling him that I'm going to go
to North Vietnam?
He's just sitting there.
Jake,
I've worked so hard with you to get you to this level.
I'm imploring you not to do this.
Oh,
Marie,
take a bed,
bed bed.
Uh,
Mary Tyler Moore episode.
Um,
God,
what a fuck.
He sort of like the first Dennis Rodman.
Like when by the time Dennis did it,
it was just,
just been so much.
First of all,
they didn't have our guys,
you know,
in,
in p and W.
Yeah.
And uh,
well I mean,
you know,
um,
what was that guy's name?
Auto warm beer.
It was a guy that,
I have no clue who that is,
but he played for the Bengals and the only one who remembers this guy's name,
I think he was from Chicago,
he was there,
he went to North Korea on vacation a few years ago and he stole a banner out of
the basement of a hotel and they sent him,
sentenced him to,
you know,
hard labor for life and then they gain back years and later on he sent him back
as a vegetable there.
It was in a coma and he died and he died.
It's heartbreaking story.
So yeah,
he went up to,
he went in there and like,
yeah,
it took that post or whatever,
which is,
you know,
something you don't do.
I remember it's somebody on,
on,
on the Internet.
It was like,
as you use the apple of white privilege,
oh my God,
this,
it's like even this,
you have to turn into that.
Yeah.
Can't we all just be like,
wow,
that's somebody's son.
Yeah.
You know,
Kent,
can't he just do that?
Do you have to turn it into like a fucking Hashtag uh,
social justice,
whatever fucking moment.
Everyone's being dehumanized.
Yeah.
I mean,
I dunno,
that was one of those sites stand.
Why anybody would go to Vietnam on vacation.
They killed so many of our,
she knew so many people that die,
you know?
And I went back in 2014 Hanoi was my favorite.
It's French tree line boulevards.
It's really,
uh,
the lake that John Mccain was shot down in a,
in the whole town.
Has Swan boats now has now a swan peddle boats?
No,
it doesn't.
I told you that.
Did you tell me that?
I did tell you she was my Boston background.
Yeah.
You can rent couples go there and rent swan paddle boats.
So that's why I don't watch people stand up special because things stick.
Here's,
I forget cause I was sitting there and oh I'm going to throw in the swan joke
thing from right when I got back.
So I went in in 2014.
This English guy who runs the Gig there and annoying also gives motorcycle tours
of the north in Vietnam.
So I went back to April of this year and um,
I went on this,
if it was my,
my dream to go on this motorcycle journey and we were 45 miles north of Hanoi
going up a mountain,
a little winding road,
the bike went out from under me and I wrecked and it doesn't say how good a
writer are you,
how's the fourth time I've been on a motorcycle and I've been afraid of
motorcycles my whole life.
So it was something I wanted to do to break my fear.
And uh,
I was wearing a helmet and my head bounced off the road,
but I was fine and uh,
took a lot of skin off my elbow.
But I think it just taking the safety course out here,
we ride around the parking lot.
My wife's brother,
my wife is from Holland,
and her brother teaches motorcycle lessons in Rotterdam.
So last summer when I was in Rotterdam visiting her family,
uh,
he took me out and,
and he and I did that in the parking lot.
So I did then how long between that and then just writing up a fucking mountain
in Vietnam?
What,
eight,
10 months later
I took my ground school and,
uh,
it didn't fly again.
And eight months later I decided to fly in a dirt bike when I was 14,
and I like tore a tendon in my arm and I missed a baseball season,
which was a big deal when you're 14.
And,
uh,
and then I didn't,
when I lived in Amsterdam and I had to,
uh,
worked,
for this Dutch travel show for a year,
I got to do a highlight on Peru and we went to the Nazca lines.
You know,
those lines that people think are alien landing strips.
They weren't discovered until the 1920s had shit on that cover.
That Zeplin box set.
Uh,
you're talking about,
he's like a really dumb guy here dude.
I don't,
that's weird.
You're like talking in English,
but half of this shit you're saying like I don't,
I don't,
I'm like,
I don't know what that is.
I'm just,
this is taking me back to high school where I'm just like,
there's these desert drawings and they weren't discovered until the 1920s when
aircraft was um,
first flying over Peru and one's,
it Condura one's a monkey and then there it looks like these landing strips in
between it and um,
yeah.
Why would you make it like that if everyone didn't know how to fly back then?
Right.
Is that what they,
they asked?
It's like a thousand years old.
It's how they have done it.
Unless aliens helped them.
Maybe just,
maybe that's the theory.
They develop some sort of hot air balloon before anybody else and then they all
perished in some sort of a plague and there,
you know,
I used everything was biodegradable back then.
How are you going to find the hot air balloon?
It doesn't always have to be aliens.
It doesn't,
yeah.
I used to do a align years ago that,
uh,
the ink is,
did cocaine,
I guess that explains why they were building a Ufo landing strips in the desert
all night.
Uh,
tell me about a couple of things I want to ask.
One of my favorite podcast episodes ever was the one that you did with the late
great John Fox,
who was,
I never met him,
but I heard all of the stories.
He was like,
um,
road viking.
I mean,
he,
like every,
he created the cliches.
Like it was kind of like,
uh,
like,
I dunno the Elvis or like,
you know,
the early days of rock and roll where there was no,
go out and go create
it and create the,
what the fuck this is going to be.
And he,
he kind of did that as far as every fucking cliche.
Now,
um,
that guy was an listening to that podcast with him because I don't need heard of
him and I never really,
you know,
and there's all these short little clips of him on the Internet just to get like
an hour,
an hour and 10 minutes,
however long it is of him telling stories.
And then just hearing the stories in his voice like that.
I that crazy laugh.
Oh my God.
Like,
uh,
amazing.
Uh,
how did you get like everybody,
I,
my buddy Paul Versey met him.
It was like,
man,
that guy was,
he was a fucking sweetheart and Diversey met them right towards the end and he
actually,
they're working on like Milwaukee or something and he watched his set and
actually gave him a couple of tags,
encouraged them and all of that.
And I dunno if he was sick yet,
but,
um,
he just was all mad.
He was like the nicest guy and all of that type of stuff.
So I'm so glad that you did that episode,
but how did you get to meet you,
John?
Um,
I worked with him when I was really young.
I think I was,
I,
I was 19 when I worked with him in Jacksonville,
Florida.
There used to be a punchline there.
It was a great room and I used to do the comedy zone down there.
This was way before that.
You know,
the Atlanta punchline in the,
in the boom,
in the late eighties,
there was punchline comedy clubs all over the south and the one in Jacksonville
was one of the best and the guys that owned it,
it was like four guys and then they all got like Mercedes and BMWs and then
they're,
they're breaking in so much money.
They moved it to a bigger venue.
They had like 150 seat room.
Then they moved it to a 500 seat room and the place was never the same.
And then it went out of business.
But at one time that was like one of the,
it was one of the greatest clubs in the south.
So I worked with him and you know,
John Fox was legendary for kind of being a womanizer,
coke freak,
booze hound,
all that.
Chan,
I check he liked me,
um,
because I,
I could drink heavily and um,
I,
I was relatively cute and um,
we would attract some ladies.
So he still had,
he was on one of the first
right,
right.
That is,
that is next level like getting pussy where it,
so I just,
that remind me of Pedro Martinez when he lost the heat on his fast ball.
So he developed a couple other pitchers and he was able to stay in the league at
a high level.
So he's sitting there crushing ass cause he was a good looking guy when he was
young.
Right.
Blonde hair had the mullet,
which was the look,
the whole Miami vice oak he could pull up was crushing ass and then all of a
sudden he starts,
you know,
loses a little heat on his fastball is like,
it's a good looking young fella.
I'll bring him along.
That'll keep bringing the ladies up to the light here.
That's the thing I think
people don't,
don't think of when they think of him.
When he,
he was on one of those early Rodney Dangerfield,
young comedian specials,
and he looked like a California surfer guy.
He had blonde hair but Tan Tan,
right shape.
And then he got older and Pudgy and he looked like an older white guy,
alcoholic dude.
So,
um,
the life caught up with him.
He helped me get in.
He loved me and he helped me get in with Chicago xannies where he was the men,
you know,
that was his hometown.
He was from Waukegan,
Illinois.
But,
um,
he was mister Chicago,
so he gets me work with him in Chicago,
booked like three weeks,
uh,
the downtown room and a couple of the suburban rooms for a couple of weeks.
I'm 19.
I'd never been to Chicago,
uh,
and it was sold out every night and he was demand,
Saika one of his porn star came and he took me to the blues brothers,
had a bar or doing cocaine after hours off to the pinball machine.
He took me,
he took me to a cubs game.
He took you under his wing.
He took me under his wing,
but it was great.
I mean,
you know,
I'd only been doing comedy for two years and I'm in Chicago playing and sold out
rooms opening for this guy.
But he took me to see the cubs and he was a,
he was kind of a Chicago celebrity back and he was buddies with Steve Stone.
And he actually took me up.
We got to go up into the booth when Harry Carey's sang,
take me out to the ballgame.
And like Harry Carey's leg half in the bag,
leaning out the window and,
um,
the had to hold his belt so he didn't fall out.
I mean,
who lead a better life than that guy gets to announce baseball while he's just
catching a buzz.
And everybody's started was hilarious that he was like,
he was literally drunk.
Yeah.
On the,
yeah.
In the afternoon.
So,
um,
yeah,
so I mean,
you know,
uh,
John Fox was really nice to me and I knew him through the years and then,
the trials and tribulations and bad relationships and years of booze and access.
Uh,
it was kind of sad,
but I mean he was kind of the cautionary tale of,
you know,
you don't want to be this road guy who,
um,
is just chasing women and partying and stuff forever because it,
uh,
it was really a sad end for that guy.
And then he lived in the apartment building next door to the apartment where the
xannies puts the comedians in Chicago.
It's an old town.
And,
uh,
there's the old town Ale House,
which I remember him taking me there and all these,
that area in the,
in the late eighties was grant.
I'm a kid and it was,
you know,
it was so much fun.
And then,
uh,
he was Kinda like sad,
lonely drunk guy at the old town Ale House.
Towards the end were,
was towards the
end,
like when,
when did it start becoming,
when did it sort of shifts where the industry wasn't,
he stopped getting work and,
um,
and I,
I sat in the nine,
Nah,
I can't remember.
Right.
I can't remember what year I did that recording with him.
I don't think it was the nineties cause when I was,
no,
it was early thousands.
Yeah.
Cause when I was in the nineties,
when I was starting to get out there on the road,
it was,
uh,
I would hear legendary stories about him.
And then everywhere I had just been,
it seemed,
Doug Stan hope was there and had some sort of debauchery in the fucking green
room.
And I remember the first time I met Doug stay and help,
uh,
you know,
I instantly loved the guy,
but before I met him I was like,
where the fuck is this Stan Hope Guy?
What the fuck can he,
you know,
do all this shit outside of the God damn,
uh,
the comedy condo and a,
but I would always hear like,
oh my God,
the Atlanta punchline,
they,
they used to have stories.
I know there's a couple of guys who are still alive,
so I don't want to fucking put this shit out there,
but there was like a couple of guys on that Mount Rushmore of like,
the wait staff would be so excited that they were coming to town.
And after like maybe a night and a half,
like that Sunday night show seemed like three years away and they would just
like,
I don't think I'm going to make it because there was those guys that came to
town and they just,
they will like this pied Piper in the entire fucking wage staff.
They had this charisma.
All the bartenders,
the club owners,
they,
he would just take them on a crawl night after night,
after fucking night.
And,
and like,
I mean,
I,
uh,
this other guy that I know of who,
I'm not going to mention his name,
like he had a nickname and all that,
and he would pick up the phone and he would just,
he would say anything like,
Tom,
you're like,
[inaudible] it's so and so.
And the running joke was you would just scream in horror knowing that he was
coming to town,
he was going to stay with you and that you guys were going to be hitting a
bottle or two every,
it would be like trying to keep up with Lemmy,
some of these guys that reminds me of some of like the Lemmy Motorhead stories
that you hear him.
So,
but when you don't have the,
um,
the,
the albums in the following to fall back on,
like,
I remember anything John Fox,
when he was still like surfer,
good looking guy.
Uh,
I remember he would walk by the waitress station and he would go,
um,
he would just announce,
fuck me before I'm famous.
He would say that out loud to the,
to the way he never would have survived the me too movement.
Oh my God.
Well,
but so when he was so towards the end and you know,
and I always had a soft spot in the,
from a hurt for the guy because he helped me when I was a young comedian.
And,
uh,
so I did that interview with him.
And,
um,
the thing that I,
that stands out for me on that interview that I did with him,
oh,
so there was,
there was one when it,
when it got sad for him,
I remember there was some turbulent,
he was
in and,
and uh,
he was falling apart and as a,
as an alcoholic and I was in this terrible relationship and the girl had
scratched his face,
like really bad.
And so he had all these scratch marks on his face.
And,
uh,
there was a story in Atlanta about him breaking down on stage and crying and
just some really sad stories and shit that happened to him.
But the thing that stands out fucking movie.
Yeah.
The thing that stands out for me about that interview was that he still believed
in love.
He's talking about and he had been through all this shit in his life and you
know,
he's,
he's an older pudgy alcoholic guy past his prime and he's still talking about
love and it's like radio,
but the standup version,
like an Arrow back in the day co he could've played John Fox like the John Fox
story.
It's the same thing.
And in the end he ends up doing stand up in raging bull.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Um,
well you,
uh,
you,
you cleaned up your act how long ago?
Uh,
I've been sober for almost five years.
That's fucking amazing.
I bet.
I finally kind of cleaned up my act.
I don't like,
I don't think I would ever not do it again,
but like I drank like the last day of June and then I drank,
uh,
August 7th,
and I'm not going drink against luck October now.
I sorta drink like the way I smoked cigars or I should say the way I would like
to smoke cigars,
which I like,
you know,
a couple times a month or every other month or something like that.
Uh,
you know,
um,
I'm trying to like,
you know,
I've got a kid,
I'm a super old fucking dad.
They have a kid.
So it's just like I have to fucking be around until this,
my kid has it figured out.
You know,
every,
every warrior needs to move on to Weissman.
Yeah,
well,
no,
you can't be out pounding it.
And,
uh,
one of the greatest things ever happened to me was given up the booze.
And I mean,
and I feasted from the banquet of life,
you know,
I,
I mean,
I lived in Amsterdam,
you know,
uh,
most of the talk show over there and then you would like the Dave Letterman talk
show for two years on Dutch television.
But,
um,
you know,
I went through some pretty hardcore tragedies.
My Dad,
who I adored,
was killed by a drunk driver in 2009 through the irony of that,
when you see that helmet,
that surviving Vietnam,
all of that and the metals and all that,
and then just some jackass in Anaheim,
which,
you know,
we've all fucking done.
So I can't,
like,
it's just fucking unbelievable.
Then.
And then my little sister,
who I was really close with,
um,
died of breast cancer in 2011,
uh,
my wife and I actually got married at her hospital bedside,
um,
the day before she died of cancer cause I didn't want her to miss it.
So that was 2011.
So 2012,
2013,
I had stopped drinking for pleasure saying I was like numbing
myself because I was so heartbroken.
And then,
um,
January 1st,
2014,
uh,
in Philadelphia,
I blacked out,
busted my head open.
And uh,
the next I got like six stitches on my forehead.
I had a black eye.
The next day I,
I looked in the mirror and I saw so much ugliness and uh,
and I knew,
I knew,
she didn't know that was the moment when you look at,
in that moment I had been thinking about it and I just thought the main,
I mean vanity was,
was a big reason because um,
I saw so much ugliness in the mirror,
but also I knew it was holding me back as a comedian.
I knew I could be a better comedian if I stop drinking every night.
And um,
you know,
and I didn't go to any AA meetings,
which a people always get offended when I say that,
but,
um,
I just,
I just had had enough and,
uh,
the first,
first couple of weeks,
you know,
you're a little a little bumpy,
but,
uh,
you know,
you can get through it just pictured you look into the mirror with the black guy
and the cut and just being like,
all right,
you win,
you win.
I'm not fucking doing this.
Well,
what happened was I looked in the mirror and I just thought,
I want to go one year when I looked in the mirror,
what I said to myself was,
I want to go one year and see what it's like not being drunk every night to be,
to see what I could get done.
And I got so much done a writing jokes and,
you know,
working on my book and different projects and stuff.
Uh,
I,
that's what made me stick around.
Yeah.
Well mine to having a kid now too.
It's like every,
every dad told him,
I said,
Oh yeah,
have a kit that will,
that will curb your drinking.
Cause they don't give a shit or have any sort of concept of what being hung over
his yeah.
And they wake up with like,
they're there on a full tank.
Like the whole body is brand new,
nothing hurts and they're ready to just,
it's just like that,
that,
that they get right in your face yelling and shit.
And it's just like,
um,
it's actually,
you know,
I'm finding if I'm going to go out and do stand up,
I have to make the,
I have to be out the door by eight o'clock,
eight oh five,
I'm going to fall asleep.
It's just one of those things like she gets up at like a quarter to seven in the
morning.
And uh,
that happened to me last night where I was like,
I'm going to go out.
I think it was actually,
I was going to go see a mission.
Impossible.
Cause I'm wanting to watch Tom Cruise,
speaking of helicopters,
flying that helicopter.
And,
um,
I just,
Oh,
the next showing isn't until 10 or 10 30.
And I knew I was like,
I'm gonna fall asleep in the middle of mission impossible.
Tom Cruise Action Summer action movie.
I am so fucking tired,
I'm going to fall asleep.
So,
uh,
plus I want to take my,
Nia long to go see it and like imax get the whole thing before,
uh,
the whole experience before it goes away.
So,
um,
let,
let me see.
Ah,
let's,
let's promote,
so you're going to be in Mongolia.
What else do you got?
Like I don't know if I have any listeners there.
That was such a great story about how supported the comics where,
because I did a Gig in India and like most of the crowd was comedians.
I was so happy that I didn't realize that cause I would have been like
intimidated.
Like,
Oh God,
they're all going to be like,
what's the next joke structure?
And afterwards we all hung out and it was like,
it was weird.
It was like I was hanging at a comedy club on the other side of the world in
like total.
They're color,
but it was the exact same fucking questions.
Did you write on stage?
He'd do that.
Yeah.
Don't you think this guy is overrated?
And they would say shit like that.
I was like,
oh my God,
it's the exact same phone.
The guys who were probably over there,
um,
uh,
emulating your gestures and stuff cause they hung out with no,
but I
do,
what I found was people in India,
a fucking hilarious that just,
they're a there,
it's kind of that same vibe of like when do you go to Ireland and Scotland?
We,
you just meet like,
like,
yeah,
this is what I love it the most like the,
you know,
the fraternity of it,
uh,
people in Australia funny.
They just fucking funny.
I don't know what it is.
And then other places you go,
I'm not going to mention is I'm going to shit on any,
he just go and they're just like,
these people are polite and then you go to these other places.
It's just like you just is the second you walk into the airport,
you just start seeing characters.
He's like,
all right,
this is going to be a good show.
These people are cool.
Oh,
I'm so glad you went to um,
that,
that um,
storer in Paris and on your podcast,
you wouldn't give the name of it.
Oh yeah.
Cause I turned you onto it.
I didn't want anyone to answer emails.
What's the name of that Patisserie?
Cause I was picturing you go in there and the next time a standing in this line,
you know,
you're all excited.
Like that fucking asshole bill set it on his podcast.
I get to stand in.
It's like,
but there's already,
the word is kind of how people already know.
And when people come up to me,
I tell them like,
like what it is.
And I actually liked the sandwich is better.
The sandwiches are amazing.
I remember what I,
what I told you what I tell everybody get one of the sandwiches because they're
incredible and then buy one for later from when you're walking around Paris and
you think to yourself,
damn,
I wish I'd of bought a another sandwich for later.
So,
and it doesn't overdo it.
It doesn't,
it just makes you want to keep going back.
So,
um,
you know a lot of that mission of possible,
I heard he's in Paris,
shot in Paris.
Yeah.
I gotta check that out,
but I keep trying to get to your date.
Okay.
All right.
Keep playing the funny bone in Mongolia.
No,
no,
no.
It's called the UBI.
Ulaan.
Baatar is called a,
they call it ubi city.
So it's the,
you,
you be city comedy club.
Um,
okay.
So check out this schedule I have for the rest of the year.
Uh,
August 22nd,
um,
in Woolen Batar Mongolia.
August 24th.
I'm in Beijing,
China.
August 25th,
Shanghai,
August 30th through September 2nd at levity live in West Nyack,
New York.
Are you driving to these gigs?
No.
Wait,
you're doing,
so you're doing this quick little,
it's that side.
Even Southeast Asia.
That's,
that's,
yeah,
no,
I did Southeast Asia in the April.
Of course.
Um,
the,
this is Maharaji Butterfly was a couple of gigs so I could have an excuse to go
back to Mongolia in summer and in check it out,
you know.
So September 4th through the ninth amid [inaudible] in Chicago,
uh,
12th through the 16th,
I'm in Rosemont Adzenys September 27th through September 30th,
I'm at the punchline in Atlanta.
I love that place.
October 4th,
I'm in Porto,
Portugal doing a comedy festival has you do a October six Lisbon,
October 12th and 13th in Paris.
The 16th through the 20th is Oslo.
The 25th through the 29 was a funny fucking people.
I Love Oslo.
It's great that they are really like fun fucking people.
I think it's my favorite place in Scandinavia.
A 25th is the 29th,
uh,
Galway,
Ireland doing that comedy festival.
And that's your potential is if you could live anywhere in the world.
You told me that I would live in Galway.
It's one of my favorite places in the world.
Uh,
the 31st is Dublin.
November 1st is Belfast,
November 3rd.
Berlin.
No,
this is why you're such a fucking interest in get you one the most interesting
people I've ever met because how do you not,
you know,
well,
I guess there are mouth breathing more on set.
Could travel this way and mouth breathing.
Sorry.
Now we're with fucking,
uh,
and their worldview wouldn't fucking change,
but yours does.
Thankfully.
I'm interrupting here.
Continue.
What else?
Do you know what I was trying to make that show where I would be the Anthony
Bourdain of comedy.
Um,
but whatever.
It'd be November 8th to the 11th.
I'm at the Improv and Addison,
the November 12th through 18 Las Vegas,
uh,
November 23rd through 27,
Tokyo,
Japan.
November 29,
two rotates again,
I'm at the Improv in Pittsburgh.
I'm actually really excited about it.
My wife was like,
no,
I've never been to Pittsburgh.
So,
um,
she used to travel with me everywhere and now she's selective where she wants to
go.
She wants to go to Pittsburgh because we've never seen it.
I can tell you,
you got to get,
there was a pre Manny,
she got to get one of those sandwiches.
Yeah,
they're Italian section with all the,
uh,
the Gaba ghoul and all that shit.
Joe Barton,
I converse,
he brought me through the,
they,
they went and got,
got it through.
Pittsburgh is one of the,
uh,
great cities.
This country has one of the great,
the only guys in America I've never put performed one of the goals,
go to a pirates game.
That view with the bridges,
it's,
it's an believable,
it's one of my favorite cities.
And when you come from the airport,
it's the greatest skyline you're going to see because it's not like you see it.
It just keeps getting bigger and bigger.
You can't see it at all.
And then you drive through like this fucking hill,
this tunnel,
and then you come out and just boom.
It says panoramic.
[inaudible] it's like all of these bridges.
There's the ballparks and everything to the left Heinz field.
Uh,
um,
what
the weather,
what did pirates play?
It's going to say pac bell.
It's where the giants used to play.
I forgot what the fuck they call it.
They change them every year.
And then,
uh,
then the skyscrapers and though they just,
there's so much to do there.
The food is unbelievable.
And the,
uh,
she'd be like,
people,
they start feel you should give out little stars for Comedians that,
uh,
that word never.
He used to do that.
Do what Willie Stargell in 1979.
Uh,
they called him pops.
Yeah.
And they had those,
there's flat hats back then.
Yep.
The old timers used to give out little stars to the his teammates that he
thought whenever they did something.
Great.
All right.
So on the back of their hats,
they had all these stars.
Do you remember that?
Yeah,
vaguely Kent to Calvin.
It was like a really cool thing about the,
I saw him on one of the last time,
one of his last public experience and to Colby,
the side arm throwing out parents is,
uh,
I saw,
yeah,
but I saw Willie Stargell when he was old.
He was sick.
You could tell he was dying.
And I was at three rivers stadium and I was watching,
uh,
the cubs first,
the pirates,
Sammy Sosa was still out in right field.
He still look Cuban,
you know,
before,
have you seen him now?
No,
he's whiter than,
um,
there was some big story about him I read recently.
Yeah.
He's,
oh,
he's living in Dubai and he's,
he looks,
yeah,
he looks like John Fox.
Yup.
Now that's what Sammy Sosa looks like.
Okay.
So,
uh,
yeah,
what?
Pittsburgh?
November 29th to December 2nd.
I don't think the pirates will be playing then I'm going to Heinz field and
then,
um,
December 10th to the 17th,
I'm in Israel doing this Israel tour and then we're having to number 20th
through the 22nd.
I'm at the Improv in Orlando,
Madagascar.
What we get,
I've never been Antarctica.
I've never,
the only con I have not,
the only continents I have not performed on is Africa and Antarctica.
Okay.
Dude,
there's gotta be some sort of expedition.
So the,
the,
the comedy Igloo,
as soon as that opens,
when the,
uh,
the 40th anniversary of the thing,
when they,
when they all go down there,
you got to,
you got to get that thing to go on to dial back the international travel next
year.
Well I want to,
how I do it is I,
I,
I'm,
I'm overdue to go,
go to Australia and I just sorta like as I get the new hour,
I just have it in my head were what hour I did the last time I was there and I
always go and,
and uh,
have a great time.
It's a lot weirder now that I have a kid.
So we set up this east of Australia.
It's just,
Sydney is one of my favorite cities in the world.
All of those cities are great.
Brisbane,
Melbourne,
Perth.
Yeah.
I came to Perth on Australia Day.
Fucking lunatics.
Who Do the El Camino was still popular,
so popular.
They love those fucking things.
That,
what's the,
I forget what they call it.
The,
it's a,
Oh,
I remember going to Australia for the first time.
I'm like,
what kind of car is that?
There's this,
this automobile brand called Holden and they still make those
cars.
They're great people were fucking shit faced driving all around.
I've told you this shit.
I said,
I went to Bond Scott's grave.
And so we went to bunny's got scratched me.
Hannah Miller genuine draft bottle on there and I wanted to remove it,
but I was like,
out of respect for the person that put it there at pawn probably would have
drank it.
He wouldn't give a fuck.
But um,
all right,
let's,
uh,
let's wrap this up here.
So I,
I just got to say you,
you're one of my favorite people,
one of my favorite comedians.
And uh,
this has been one of the best podcasts I've done as far as just like fascinating
fucking store.
I mean,
everything we had life death here.
What'd he say?
Heroic behavior here or rhythm.
Is that a word?
Heroism.
Heroism,
yeah.
I've been to a lot of countries too and it just doesn't seem to have walking
sticks on,
man.
I,
thanks for having me on,
man.
I,
uh,
you're one of my favorite people to hang out with every time you and I get
together and we just like hang out as buddies.
I always get material out of it.
You know,
I was telling you that story about,
because I pronounced so many words incorrectly,
I was just gonna say,
I can't imagine how many,
how many fucking countries I've been to.
And I still sound like I've never left my block.
I mean it's just a great,
um,
I was telling you about arguing with my wife because she wants me to clean the
toilet and like I don't,
I don't want to clean the toilet.
Right.
And um,
you know,
a lot of thoughts go through my head during the day,
watching movies,
sleep on the couch,
call a friend,
cleaning the toilet is not one of them.
And we live in an apartment building.
So this is what it's like to argue on an apartment building.
You make a valid point.
Now lower your voice because I don't want everybody in my building,
no of my business.
I'm in the laundry room,
folding clothes.
Some guy walks in there,
I know you,
you're the dude.
He don't clean the toilet.
So like I've been doing the effort,
I've just started doing that like in the last two weeks.
And that comes from having a conversation with you on my balcony smoking
cigarettes or cigars.
Yeah.
You're one of those guys.
You're always spitting out material and you don't realize it.
I go you to go.
Don't waste that on me.
You better do that instead.
Yeah.
I used to get an argument with me.
Neil was still living in an apartment.
We used to,
uh,
she didn't give a fuck and she calls it,
she's passionate.
So this is when she would occasionally throw shit at me or punch me in the
chest.
This is back her younger wilder days.
And I remember,
uh,
we would get into,
and I would lose so many arguments because she didn't give a fuck about volume.
And I would always be calling like,
alright,
here's your bait to point.
You don't want to help the whole fucking world know about it.
I said,
they get loud.
So then what's worse is you start whispering.
So only your shit is coming out.
And all the neighbors like,
oh my God,
he's horrible.
He's not even arguing.
She's so fucking right.
That's where they get you when they get loud on.
Yeah.
Well anyways,
uh,
so great that you finally came on finally.
Got You on.
I think it's cause we also love smoking cigars and telling stories.
So it's like why would have a podcast get in the way of that?
Um,
um,
I'm so glad you came on and you get to promote your dates here.
So go see him in Mongolia.
If not,
you can see him in Pittsburgh.
Atlanta.
Nayak West Niasha.
Yes.
Orlando.
You know,
I still,
I still play everywhere,
all over the states.
And you have a great life.
I majored in like radio communication where you got a great radio,
but I wish somebody would give me a voiceover gigs.
Huh?
You know,
this town is,
you got to take it.
I'm running through the grass.
I'm on my tippy toes.
Um,
definitely check him out.
He's going to be everywhere and if he's going to travel that fucking far,
you can travel a little bit to go see him.
Uh,
the great Tom Rhodes,
everybody,
thank you so much for coming on.
Here's a little music for you.
And then we get it.
We have a bonus half hour of a greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon podcasts
from earlier this year or years ago.
I don't know.
I don't decide.
All right.
Have a great weekend and I'll talk to you on Monday.